[تصفيق]
اكبر حراس العالم يا سوداء
الالماني حارس عرين المنشاوي العملاق
البذاري مانويل نوير احد افضل حراس المرمى
في تاريخ اللعبه انضم لاحدى مدارس كره
القدم برفقه زميله وكان يرغب في اللعب في
مركز المهاجم لكن جسده الضيئيل حال دون
ذلك انضم لنادي شولكه الذي كان يعشقه منذ
الصغر وقدم اداء مبهرا رغم صغر سنه
موهبته الفاده اليه الانظار فانتقل الى
بايرن ميونخ في صفقه تاريخيه جعلت منه
ثانيه اغلى حارس مرمى في تاريخ كره القدم
بعد الايطالي بوفون بدات علاقته بالجماهير
البذاريه المتوفره كونه ازاحه من النادي
المتالق تونس ليحل محله لكنه سرعان ما خطف
قلوب الجماهير لتصدياته المذهله احداها
صنف ضد من الافضل في دوري ابطال اوروبا
تصدى لتسديده نجم ريال مدريد كريستيانو
رونالدو التي بلغت سرعتها 190 كم في
الساعه برضه فعلا قدرت بثلاثه اجزاء من
الثانيه حتى مرقم مواطنه الاسطوره اوليفر
كان بالحفاظ على نظافه شباكه لمده 1000
دقيقه مع بايرن ميونخ حقق عددا من
البطولات في مقدمتها لقبا دوري ابطال
اوروبا ومع المانشاف حقق اللقب الاعلى
بالفوز بكاس العالم 2014
في التدريبات قبل اعلان القائمه الرسميه
الحارس الاسطوري يسعى لتحقيق انجاز
تاريخيا في قطر وضمك كاس ثاني لجوابته
المليئه بالبطوله
[تصفيق]